today on the matt welsh show i have
found the next school board that i'll be
visiting but i'm not going alone this
time i'll tell you about that today also
the recall of governor newsom in
california fails miserably what can we
as conservatives learn from that if
anything plus i have a few thoughts on
the tragic death of mor mcdonald and
what about the story of general milly
going directly to the chinese government
to circumvent trump isn't that treason
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
deal with this question is it white
supremacy to tell kids in school to be
quiet and behave themselves one teacher
thinks so and he shared his thoughts on
tick tock we'll talk about that today
and much more on the matt walsh
[Music]
last month the far left school board in
loudoun county virginia passed one of
the most far-reaching and radical trans
policies in the country under the new
rules male students who identify as
female will be able to use female
restrooms in locker rooms of course
females who identify as males will be
able to do the reverse but you notice
that there are never as many girls
wanting to access the boys locker room
as there are boys wanting to access the
girls locker room
same for sports teams a strange
coincidence isn't it
but the policy goes beyond sports teams
and locker rooms it also requires
teachers to use the preferred pronouns
of their students
now magnanimously teachers will not be
punished if they have an unintentional
slip and accidentally utter an incorrect
read correct pronoun but any teacher who
intentionally and with malice a
forethought dares to use proper grammar
in their classroom will be in violation
and you know suffer the so far vaguely
outlined consequences
this part of the policy is particularly
odious i mean it's all odious but this
presents special complications because
gender confused kids
can quite literally change their
pronouns on a daily or hourly basis
that's part of what it means to be
fluid like i mean it doesn't really mean
anything to be fluid but if it means
anything
it means that it can change
by the second maybe
and they might invent new pronouns on
the spot they might demand that their
teachers speak an absolute gibberish
and the teacher will be expected to
remember which gibberish
and then change to different gibberish
if they're instructed to do so
all in all teachers are being made to
affirm falsehoods to speak untruths to
babble incoherently to reject the rules
of grammar and the english language and
ultimately to abandon their role as
educator in favor of becoming high
priests of the leftist religion
now many teachers in the county and
across the country
seem more than happy to fill this role
we're already filling it many of them
but some have resigned in protest or
filed lawsuits to challenge the new
rules one teacher tanner cross
an elementary physical education
instructor in the district was fired
after speaking out against the policy
during a meeting a school board meeting
a few months ago let's listen to his
remarks again because they were it's
very brief but but powerful and true
here he is
my name is tanner cross and i'm speaking
out of love for those who suffer with
gender dysphoria
60 minutes this past sunday interviewed
over 30 young people who transitioned
but they felt that astray because lack
of pushback or how easy it was to make
physical changes to their bodies in just
three months they are now
de-transitioning it's not my intention
to hurt anyone but there are certain
truths that we must face when ready we
condemn school policies like 80 40 and
80 35 because it will damage children
defy defile the holy image of god i love
all of my students but i will never lie
to them regardless of the consequences
i'm a teacher but i serve god first and
i will not affirm that a biological boy
can be a girl and vice versa because
it's against my religion it's lying to a
child it's abuse to a child and it's
sinning against our god
now cross was as i said fired for that
he was fired for disagreeing with the
school board
that they decided is is a an offense
worthy of termination
fortunately a judge stepped in and
reinstated across his position
clarifying that school boards cannot in
fact fire teachers for disagreeing with
them it's public comments
you're supposed to give up stand up
there and give your opinion
and they fired him for giving an opinion
they don't like
tanner is
one teacher taking a brave stance
against sinister lunacy
there are others and there are parents
too but they're outnumbered and so i
would like to help change that that's
why i will personally be coming to
loudoun county virginia on september
28th which is the date of their next
school board meeting to help lead a
rally against all of this madness the
rally will be at 5 pm on september 28th
at 21 000 education court in ashburn
now some of us will also try to speak
during the meeting itself but the board
has changed the rules in recent months
to make it harder to do that they won't
allow crowds inside the building during
public comments they can set the time
limit for public comments down to one
minute if they decide
these are obviously tactics meant to
mute voices of dissent which is why i
want to show up with hundreds and
hundreds of those voices and set up shop
right outside the building
and i'm asking anyone in the vicinity to
come and make your voice heard as well
now i can tell you from my part that
you know i don't want to just hang out
on the sidelines and complain into a
camera anymore i mean i'm still going to
complain to the camera but
my efforts will will go beyond that um
those who
push evil and insanity must be
confronted directly in person
schools that harm children have to be
confronted
that we can all sit around lamenting the
disintegration of our culture saying oh
man isn't it too bad that they're
mutilating the minds and souls and
bodies of a generation of children gee
what a shame
oh well let's see what else is on tv
or we can get up get out and do
something about it
there's power in numbers but those
numbers have to be mobilized and brought
together in one place
numbers don't mean anything all this
stuff about being a silent majority
i hate that phrase
silent majority i don't think it's true
i don't know if it's true i doubt that
it's true i almost hope that it isn't
because shame on us if we're in the
majority still
and silent
doesn't mean anything is that anything
to be proud of
we're the majority and we're too afraid
to say anything yay go us
numbers don't mean anything if we are
silent and fractured and disorganized
and too afraid to speak above a whisper
content to voice our disapproval through
you know sad-faced emojis on social
media
now i announced this rally on twitter a
couple days ago and already i've heard
from the opposition in loudoun county
uh they are to say the least not happy
that we're coming
more than one person has threatened
violence against me
these are people who are so determined
to rob young girls of their privacy and
their identity that they will threaten
to assault or kill you if you try to
prevent it
they believe so strongly that boys
should be in the girl's bathroom that
they will they say commit violent
felonies to ensure that it happens
now that that makes me afraid
not for myself i'm still coming you're
not going to scare me away but for the
kids whose minds and bodies these
slobbering maniacs
these these
predator freaks are trying to destroy
another criticism i've heard is that i'm
not from loudoun county
i'm an outside agitator they say this is
none of my business
well even if that's true
i'm making it my business
protecting children is everybody's
business opposing child abuse is
everybody's business
i don't care where kids are being harmed
doesn't make any it doesn't become any
less outrageous or any less of a concern
if it's happening in a different zip
code
your zip code is different go away and
let us brainwash these kids in peace
sorry i don't find that argument
terribly compelling and besides outside
forces national advocacy groups
hollywood media politicians routinely
inject themselves into these issues to
ensure that schools and towns and states
are run as they prefer
i can guarantee that if a school board
passed a rule forbidding biological
males from entering the female restroom
hollywood celebrities and the human
rights campaign and cnn and all the rest
of them would be chiming in on the issue
calling for boycotts everything else
and none of the people telling me to
butt out my my business would be saying
the same to them
so this is a one-way street when they
need reinforcements from national
figures they're not shy about going out
and getting them
but if the other side does the same
suddenly they become firm proponents of
the principles of subsidiarity
i'm not going to abide by rules that
change depending on whose side they
benefit
not going to happen
so complain all you want tell me i don't
belong tell me this is not my concern
threaten to kill me i'm still going to
be there
one other point
tanner cross in his brief but uh but but
really great speech was correct that
this is a religious rights issue
um
also it's also correct to argue as as i
just have that this is a privacy and
safety issue
okay all of that is true
and those are the those seem to be the
main
points that that that we on this side
the same side
uh make that you know this religious
liberty
it it infringes on privacy of girls and
locker rooms and it's also unsafe like
those that's all true those are all good
points
but this is also we have to keep
insisting
something bigger and broader than that
more than anything else more important
than religious rights
or even safety
is truth
this is about truth
truth is the most important thing truth
is more important than liberty it's more
important than than life itself there
could be no liberty without truth there
could be no life at least not a life
worth living without truth
all of the good things in life love
freedom you name it all of it they're
all predicated on truth
they all exist within truth
the trans agenda is more than anything
an attack on truth it is an attempt to
build a society which fundamentally
rejects and does not recognize truth
they want us all to live outside of
truth
they want our kids to be educated in
lies
in darkness not in truth not in light
that's the battle we're fighting first
and
foremost it will certainly take more
than a rally at a school board to win
that fight but you have to start
somewhere
and so i hope you'll join us
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you haven't done it yet you
really have to taste moinks meat um
i wish i'd phrased that differently you
know the reason i love moiq is that you
get the highest quality meat that you've
ever tasted while supporting real family
farms moich delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild caught alaskan
salmon directly to your door helping
family farms become financially
independent outside of big agriculture
their animals are raised outdoors their
fish swim wild in the ocean and moink
meat is free of antibiotics hormone
sugar and all other junk that you'll
find in pre-packaged uh in the
pre-packaged meat aisle sign up at
mointbox.com walsh to get a year of
bacon for free and then you can pick the
meats you want delivered with your first
box you could change what you get each
month and you can cancel any time moic
was founded by an eighth generation
farmer who was featured on shark tank
host kevin o'leary said it's the best
bacon he's ever tasted i've also tasted
the bacon and i can tell you that uh
along with all the other meat it is
delicious so
join the movement today go to
moicbox.com walsh right now and
listeners to this show will get one
year of bacon for free that's one year
of the best bacon you'll ever taste but
for a limited time spelled m o i n k box
dot com slash walsh that's monkbox.com
walsh
you know they uh
aoc's uh fans have been desperate to
come up with a defense for
her showing up to the met gala
to drink cocktails with rich people
supposedly in an attempt to you know
this was this was her dunking on the
rich people by showing up to their party
right and hanging out with them and
taking pictures with them
but i thought this was it it's a really
hard thing to defend
so in fairness to people on that side to
aoc's fans to her groupies
it's pretty indefensible
so when you're trying to come up with a
defense there's
there's not a lot available to you there
isn't a good argument available to you
but i thought this from isaac saul who's
the founder of something called tangle
news
he said he said this is this is all
about envy and jealousy really all the
people who are accusing aoc of having a
double standard being a hypocrite he
says every single person on this website
tweeting about aoc would cut off one of
their own fingers to go to the met gala
and interact with the people they spend
all day tweeting about
is that you do you really think that
isaac you actually think that
you as a man
you you think that most people including
men
are dying to go to the met gala
we would just cut off our fingers to go
there and hang out with celebrities
that's actually my nightmare i would cut
off my i cut off my hands to not go
if i was given a choice
between going to the mega only two
choices go to the met gala or cut off
your hand
i'm saying hand me the butcher knife
that it's not even a that's not even a
tough choice to make
already like going to any event of that
sort is already my nightmare you take
away all the left-wing crazies and all
the degenerate you know celebrities that
are there
it's already a nightmare for me
everyone's in formal attire you're just
kind of like there's nothing to do
you're just sort of hanging around
there's no there's no central
activity
for everyone to do you're not watching
anything okay so you're all what do you
do you just you hang around you make
small talk the entire time
absolute nightmare
um
and i i've been involved in certainly
not the met gala but go to fundraising
banquets
i've been to a lot of fundraising
banquets in my in my day and that's what
the met gala
is uh supposedly been been to a lot of
fundraisers i've i've spoken at a lot of
fundraising banquets and i can tell you
for sure
like getting up in front of everybody
and speaking for me is
much less nerve-wracking than having to
filter around the crowd and talk to
people and then you and then you then
you factor in the people that are there
it makes it it makes it hell so
this this is why again we can't like i
can't share a country with these people
this is why the country needs to break
apart
i don't know how to share a country with
the kind of man who thinks that most men
are dying to go to the met gala
he's living in a different universe
i don't know i don't know who this
person is where they're coming from
speaking of a different universe
california um
this is from cnn now california's
democratic governor gavin newsom has
defeated the effort to remove him from
office according to a projection from
the cnn decision desk capping off a
recall effort that was born in partisan
anger over his pandemic response
but ended with a vote of confidence in
his strategy to combat it
um
he gave a speech and said a bunch of
stuff we're not gonna play any of those
clips because who cares
uh
the
you know the final tally here
appears to be not very close but what i
was really interested in
some of this exit polling data
so it says about 45
of the electorate say that newsome's
policies on the pandemic have been have
been about right
with about one-third calling his
policies too strict and the remainder
saying they're not strict enough
according to a california exit poll
conducted by cnn
or for cnn
um there's broad support for coveted
mitigation method measures in the state
with more than six in ten saying that
getting
vaccinated is more of a public health
responsibility than it is a personal
choice
the pandemic remains at the top of
voters minds with about one-third the
highest share of any issue
saying it's the biggest issue for the
state according to the exit poll
so you have the majority of voters who
either are in favor of the pandemic
response
which has decimated civil liberties in
the state
decimated small businesses
a majority are either in favor of it say
this this is just right
or they want more california has not
gone far enough they're hungry for more
restrictions on their liberty
they're going to the government and
saying i am still too free
and there there are there are still some
small businesses that have survived and
i don't think they should
take away everything else
come to my house put a padlock on my
front door and lock me in my home
you could chain me to my couch how about
as long as you keep the tv on
and um and put a straw in my mouth and
just start feeding me the entire time
like a gerbil
that's what they want but put me in a
just put me in a glass case like a
gerbil put a put some feeders there
and as long as i have a tv i'll be good
that's the attitude of many of these
voters in california
i think the effort to recall newsom was
admirable
i think it was the right thing to do to
hold him
accountable at least to some extent or
at least or attempt to hold him
accountable
uh i larry elder put in a great effort
he'd certainly be a much better governor
than gavin newsom that's not saying much
i mean i think larry elder would be a
good governor uh on his own merits
but you know an actual gerbil would be a
better governor than than gavin newsom
so all of that is good you know worth
the effort and everything but
i can tell you that i never had any hope
in this effort at all
you know i i
never really entertained the possibility
that voters would come out and vote for
a republican
especially a you know an actual
conservative republican
not a celebrity like schwarzenegger who
says that he's a republican especially
liberal
there's very little chance of really no
chance of that happening
because
this is california
and as hard as it is for us to
understand
for many of us to understand this is
what many of the people there want
you know i go to california as i was
just in california recently
you know and you go to
los angeles or san francisco many of the
cities in california
and it's a dystopian wasteland
it was already trending in that
direction before covid
but this has been the nail in the coffin
and so someone like me i could i could
wander around los angeles in in
disgusted
and thinking how can anyone want to live
like this
and that's bad enough but it's worse to
realize that in fact lots of people do
want to live like that
you know we live california is the way
that california is
because of the people of california
that is
the sad stark reality that we need to
start confronting
it's easy enough to blame the elites and
the ruling class and the government and
the media
hollywood academia we could place to
blame all in all of those places
you know all of the rich powerful people
and they deserve an immense amount of
the blame i i spend plenty of time
blaming them and pointing fingers at
them and we should
but the rot goes deeper than that
it goes into the population
and when it comes down to it
california is the way that california is
because of the people of california
because that's the state that's the
culture that they want
many of them may want it because they've
been brainwashed into wanting it they've
been convinced of it they've been
cajoled into it
but it's still it's what they want
and the responsibility lies with them
ultimately
our country is in the state that it's in
because many of the people in this
country want it that way
this is uh
maybe one of the reasons why i can never
fully carry the mantle of populism
and maybe populism doesn't need to be
this way but
very often people call themselves
populous
all they ever do is point to the
the people at the top of the food chain
the rich and powerful
but i think we need to start looking
amongst ourselves
and realizing that the problem is also
the people
uh and that's a that's a that's a much
harder problem to fix because then you
realize that
even if you even if it succeeded i mean
it would have been great
if if the recall election had succeeded
you kicked governor newsom out
at a minimum you've penalized him
for being in being incompetent and also
being a tyrant
being a horrible man and a horrible
governor horrible leader so you've held
him accountable that you've punished him
but that's probably the only benefit
that's the only good that would have
come of it
because you get a republican governor
in there for a few years
that doesn't do anything to change the
cultural rot
and if we're not willing to confront the
fact
that the rock goes all the way down into
the population into the people
into our homes and in our communities
that we're going to continue with this
idea
that we can solve all of our problems
just by electing the right people
and yet elections come and go and
sometimes they work in our favor
sometimes they don't but you notice the
cultural decay continues a pace no
matter who is in charge
donald trump was the president for four
years
culturally societally speaking
what good did it actually do
can anyone say that we're in a better
spot today culturally than we would have
been
had it been a democrat in office maybe
but now we're just talking about degrees
of badness yeah it's bad but it would
have been like one degree more bad
that's what happens when all we ever do
is focus
on the people at the top
and we don't start looking around us
all right let's go next to
uh the daily beast says nor macdonald
has died after a long and private battle
with cancer his management team
confirmed on tuesday the highly
influential stand-up comedian and former
anchor of weekend update on saturday
live was 61
uh scheduled to perform at the new york
comedy festival this nov november had
reportedly been sick with an undisclosed
form of cancer for nine years
but declined to make his illness public
uh
i just you know as many people have said
i'm not one to be affected by celebrity
deaths
this one hurts
this might be the only one i can think
of right there might have been a few
others but right now is the only one i
can think of that actually
made much of an impact on me norm
mcdonald was a was a brilliant comedian
uh one of the last real comedians that
we have that we had in this country
it also almost feels
wrong
there are a lot of
very genuine and emotional and touching
tributes that people have been doing to
norman macdonald
which in one way he's deserving of it
but another way it feels wrong because
nor macdonald himself never would have
engaged in that you know if more
mcdonald was around he'd be making fun
of his own death right um because he
never
you know he always stayed on message and
for him the message was the comedy was
the joke
but when i think about this
and we would talk about his career and
everything and eulogize him that way but
this um
the long and private battle with cancer
he had cancer for nine years and never
told anyone certainly never made it
public
i'm going i assume that some people in
his family knew i don't know that but i
think we could assume it
but it seems that nobody
even his
friends
um and fellow comedians no one knew
about it
there's something about that it's it's
obviously very sad but there's something
actually inspiring about that
and the word inspiring has been horribly
cheapened in our culture when we call
everything inspiring
but um
you know tick tock videos are supposed
to be inspiring this is really inspiring
that
he was dying of cancer
and chose to carry that burden himself
and not just
carry it himself and not tell anybody
but he was still out there telling jokes
and making people laugh
you know in in a society where we
most of us are inclined to
whine and complain publicly about every
pain we have every misfortune
we stub our toe and then next thing you
know there's a there's a ten tweet
thread we're doing about it and the the
you know the larger implications of our
stubbed toe and everything we've learned
from this is a tragedy of stubbing our
toe and now we gotta go to therapy for
the stuff to you know
in this society where where we tend to
operate that way
uh to see this i think is a is a nice
corrective
someone who
chose to live with dignity
didn't need to go out there and
fish for for pity from people
and that seems foreign to a lot of us
because
for a lot of people in this culture
there's this instinctive need for pity
where even if there's no reason for
anyone to pity you
you feel like you have to come up with a
reason
that we talk about all the time the the
victimhood competition
everyone wrestling with each other to
who's going to be the uber victim
and then of course
in that kind of environment where
everybody wants to be a victim
if something actually bad happens to you
well then of course you're gonna be
you're gonna be spreading that
everywhere hey everybody listen to this
really bad thing that's happening to me
uh but norm mcdonald didn't do that at
all he had a terrible thing that he was
going through and he chose to suffer
suffer it privately
and uh still
go about his life make people laugh i
find that extremely admirable
uh and uh and very rare we we don't see
that very often the only other example i
can think of chadwick uh bozeman
black panther actor
it was the same thing when he died of
cancer came as a shock to everyone he
hadn't told anybody and he was acting
and never made it public so
on a rare occasion you see this and i
find it incredibly
admirable and inspiring
and
you know
we we could all take a take a couple
pages from that book
i think probably
all right next what else we got here
jimmy kimmel
i hate to go to jimmy kimmel now
actually i'm going to but
this makes noor mcdonald's death eve
all them all the more are sad
you go from nor mcdonald brilliant
comedian a real comedian to jimmy kimmel
who is the least funny jimmy on late
night tv and that's a stiff competition
for that title
i'm not
saying this because of his ideology i
don't like his politics although i don't
like his politics
but i've never
heard jimmy kimmel
tell a funny joke
ever i'm not aware of any funny jimmy
kimmel joke i think he's had he's had
some funny bits that he does
uh in skits and things but i've i've
never he does these monologues every
single night
thousands and thousands of jokes that
he's told in his monologues has there
been a single funny one
i'm not sure but this one certainly is
not the first funny one let's listen
it is ridiculous but this is an
interesting statistic covet deaths have
proven to be much higher in states that
voted for trump
basically if your state has more geds
than phd's stay indoors
of the 54 000 americans who died from
covid since the start of the summer
almost one of five one in five of them
died in florida
which my god all those orphan ferrets
it's a shame
okay so
there's
making fun of everyone that died in
florida because everyone who if you died
in florida
then uh then
your death is is mockable
many of the people who died of code in
florida i mean i got news for jimmy
kimmel not everyone in florida is
is a republican
so in fact some of those people were
even democrats who died
may surprise you to learn
a total disdain
that these people have
it is it is true to say that they wish
death on us they want us to die
that's not being overly dramatic
because there's no there's no real joke
there
i i have no problem you can tell jokes
about death you could tell jokes about
things that don't seem to be funny at
all nor macdonald was great at that
any kind of tragedy you can name he's
told told jokes about 911 and they were
funny
so it's not like there's anything that's
off limits for jokes but there's no joke
here
it's simply he hates these people and
he's just snickered this is this is just
going up to someone's funeral and
pointing at at the headstone and
laughing that's all it is
because it turns out
you can't really be a funny comedian
when you're filled with hate and
contempt
and you certainly you can't tell funny
jokes about someone
if you hate them
that was one of the secrets of for
norman mcdonald i think
that he didn't he respected me he didn't
hate he told he told edgy jokes
he told jokes about people dying but he
didn't he didn't hate anyone
when you're filled with hate and
contempt there's there can't there's not
gonna be any humor in that
but with all that said
uh i'm not angry to hear jimmy kimmel
making jokes like that
everyone in red states uh they all have
geds not
phds of course that's not true but i
don't even consider that an insult
personally i would rather be around a
bunch of geds than a bunch of phds
and very often the geds are going to be
smarter
you know the phds have educated
themselves into a coma
um
but
it
it doesn't bother me for him to come out
and say in fact i'm glad that he says it
the more that these people
expose themselves and take the mask off
and expose themselves for who they are
and make their their true feelings known
i think uh the better
because this is this is the country we
live in now
and there are lots of people especially
the ones that you see on tv all the time
who really hate you and want you to die
and it's important for you to uh
for you to understand that
all right let's see what else here this
one the daily wire says in their new
book herald journalists bob woodward and
robert costa claim that general mark
milley the chairman of the joint chiefs
of staff was so concerned that then
president donald trump would go rogue
and spark a war with china that he made
a pair of secret phone calls to his
counterpart point in china per the
washington post
um it says according to a cnn write-up
woodward and costa
right that after january 6th milly felt
no absolute certainty that the military
could control or trust trump and
believed it was his job as a senior
military officer to think the
unthinkable and take any and all
necessary precautions according to a cnn
write-up up
millie was so fearful of trump attacking
china that he appears to have undermined
the trump administration and
communicated directly with chinese
officials
it says in a pair of secret phone calls
general mark milley chairman of joint
chief staff a shortage chinese
counterpart
of the people's liberation army that the
united states would not strike
one call took place on october 30th 2020
four days before the election
that unseated president trump and the
other on january 8 2021 two days after
the capital siege capital siege yeah
um
shockingly according to woodward and
costa it seems millie communicated
sensitive information to a chinese
general
and suggested that he would warn china
ahead of time if he discovered that
trump planned to attack them so this is
the definition of treason
we we heard for years and years that
trump was committing
treason that he was a traitor
he was
two unsuccessful attempts
at impeaching him were based on that
idea
they never could provide any evidence
for it whatsoever
never they could never provide any
evidence for for that charge other than
well he basically their their evidence
was that trump to them seems like the
kind of guy who would be a traitor who
would commit treason
and so we're going to spend four years
trying to find evidence to support this
assumption that we made at the very
beginning based on nothing
now we have
actual treason i mean if the word
treason means anything legally then it
would have to mean this
you have the chairman of joint chiefs of
staff
going behind the president's back
circumventing him
and having private secret conversations
with a military leader
of a foreign enemy country
if that's not trees and what is
and yet we know
that there will be no consequences
whatsoever
he's not gonna be tried
he's not gonna be charged with anything
the media won't even admit that that
there was anything wrong here
in fact for them the story is this is
all about how bad trump was
they want us to just to believe that the
story
is that mark milley felt it necessary to
take those steps
so gee
once again that's how terrible trump was
i you know republicans once again are
talking a big game and they're saying
they're going to have hearings they're
going to look into this
i hope they do
and i hope they follow through but
you know my fear is going to be just
like it was with benghazi there were we
heard about benghazi for
years and years and years and the
republicans did all kinds of hearings
about it and they talked about it on the
campaign trails and it came up you know
on cable news and they talked about it
on fox and things like that um but then
was anybody ever held accountable for it
did anything real actual actually happen
were there any tangible consequences for
anybody
i don't think there was and i don't
expect that there will be in this case
sadly
finally from study fines it says
overeating obviously leads to excess
weight right well a team of scientists
says not so fast it's actually what you
eat not how much you eat that leads to
obesity their study finds processed food
and rapidly digestible carbohydrates may
be what's really behind society's
growing waistline
they did a whole study on this and
there's an entire article suggesting
that um
it's not just about the quantity of the
food it's also the type of food
so if you're eating a lot of food but
it's healthy
and there's good protein and you're
eating fresh vegetables and that sort of
thing
then you're not going to get fat but if
you're eating a lot of fast food then
you will that's they needed a whole
study to tell us that
this is not
complicated we have been on this mission
for years to make obesity seem
complicated
and every week there's a new study oh
maybe this is what's behind the obesity
epidemic
this is not it's not a complicated thing
you don't need to be a scientist you
don't need to do any studies about it
whatsoever
if you're eating a lot of junk food
and we all know what junk food is
we don't need to define it it's kind of
like the definition of pornography the
supreme court justice
i don't know what it is but i know it
when i see it so we all know what junk
food is
you eat a lot of that and you don't get
exercise you get fat
you eat healthy food and you also move
around throughout the day and get some
exercise you won't get fat
it really is that simple
we're all sitting around getting fatter
and fatter eating doritos and watching
tv
and looking at our waistlines bulge and
bulge
and saying i don't know why this is
happening someone should do another
study about this what is going on
every day i get on the scale and there's
more the number is higher how is this
possibly happening
chomp
another dorito
not complicated all right let's get now
to reading the youtube comments
rocking polka dotted
without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
there it is sweet baby gang anthem as
promised you better get used to hearing
that because you're going to hear it
every day it will haunt your dreams um
this is from rachel says one of my
husband's male friends broke up with him
on the phone his excuse was i don't want
to go to your wedding if no one's
wearing masks
and one minute later finalized it with
saying yeah i'd prefer we actually just
stopped talking
well he he really did
your husband a favor um
that is that's no friend and that's no
man in the first place so
no loss at all there
i mean i know it's got to be pretty
upsetting because first he's not coming
to your wedding and then says i i don't
want to see you ever again
but really okay no loss for me in my
life that should be the attitude
um
zbw says matt will you cancel the ravens
for losing last night yeah i really
should but you know what this this is
what the nfl season is now it's always a
war of attrition
and i'm not sure what exactly causes it
but the injuries you know the ravens i
don't know but there's like three people
in the audience who care about this but
i'm talking about anyway the ravens lost
their entire they lost their entire
running back core they lost three
running backs
uh mostly to non-contact injuries in
practice on acl tears
and then uh this is all in the off
season
then they lost their starting cornerback
to an acl tear
they've got like 14 guys on on ir and
there's been one game
but every season it's it's like this and
it's easy to say that the game is faster
and more violent now actually it is
faster but it's not really more violent
than it was you know 20 or 30 years ago
or even 10 years ago
that even that can't be the explanation
anyway because so many of these injuries
are non-contact there are so many
achilles tears
acl tears
and now it's at the point where if you
win the super bowl if
you can keep most of your players off of
the stretcher
um okay
tina says my son had a small sore throat
today so i kept him home i lied when i
called and said his back hurts uh can't
have him staying home for two weeks for
nothing which is the policy another
comment like this from lexi bell says my
children's doctor canceled their why
their well-child checkup because both of
them had a runny nose that day symptom
of covid so we have a doctor who won't
see sick patients
yeah and you have no choice first of all
tina i don't blame you for lying at all
what choice do you have
these schools that have this policy
which as i said yesterday
if you don't think about it at all
might for a second at first blush seem
like it makes sense well if your kid has
covid symptoms don't send them to school
okay fine until you realize that coveted
symptoms are everything everything is a
symptom of code
any kind of
physical discomfort at all
could be a symptom of covet
so what they're really saying is if your
child is feeling anything less than 100
totally perfect
not only can you not send them to school
but you got to quarantine them and then
we might have to quarantine the whole
class it's not feasible you can't
function that way
and now they're doing this in doctor's
offices too
and there are real consequences to that
there are real consequences in schools
where you're shutting schools down now
for no reason
kids are continue to be deprived of an
education
not that they were getting much of an
education to begin with in the public
school
but then in doctor's offices so wait
your child can't go in for a wellness
checkup
what if he's not well
i mean what if he has some underlying
problem that the checkup may have
determined
now we're not going to know about that
and there have been a lot of people we
it's there's no way to know how many
there's no way to really quantify it but
there have been
many people who have died of cancer
or other diseases uh because they
weren't able to go to the doctor or they
were afraid to go to the doctor
they are they have been made to be
afraid to go to the doctor
because of covet
so it is a terrible situation
uh tjc says there is no way matt walsh
is using relief band such a hilarious
image how could you accuse me of that
tjc i love and adore and cherish all of
my sponsors
and anytime i'm getting in the car i
always make sure that i strap my relief
band on why is that a
funny image to you i don't understand it
uh max rex says matt stop stop standing
up for the woman who got her ass beat
she deserved it for participating in
that
yeah that's true the woman who
participated in the mma fight against
the the man
i mean i spent most of my the daily
cancellation yesterday criticizing the
announcers who went along with this
spectacle and pretended to be
pretended very unconvincingly to um
to support it
yes you blame them
you also blame the man himself for being
a cheater
but that's true that woman chose to get
in the ring she chose also to be a
participant
and she didn't have to make that choice
um that doesn't make it any
that doesn't make it better it doesn't
take any of the guilt off of the guy
yes the woman chose to get in the ring
with you
but that still doesn't excuse you
when now you're beating her across the
head fracturing her skull as fallon fox
did on multiple occasions
choking her into submission just because
she chose to get in the ring with you
doesn't make it okay for you
but i think you're correct that we got
to start pointing the fingers at the
women as well these female athletes
that would be one solution
when a tran quote-unquote trans athlete
shows up
a man says he wants to fight women every
single woman should say i am not going
to do that
but he's not going to have any
competitors
and
makeshift electric says the spg anthem
didn't play during the reading the
comments section
i feel
betrayed yeah we do have this whole
graphic we want to put together and that
was going to be paired up with the with
the spg anthem but i said you know what
we got we got to play it now we can't
wait for for
anything we've waited too long the
people need the anthem and uh we need it
now in our society more than ever and
now we have it
and and i expect that will make
everything better i'm not sure if i've
ever mentioned this to you before but um
rockauto.com
is a great place to find any auto parts
that you might need rather than
going to an auto parts store and dealing
with the fuss and hassle of all of that
rockauto.com a lot easier than that you
know what you know what else it's also
the lowest prices possible they're not
going to change their prices uh they're
going to be honest with you and you know
that if you find it on rockauto.com
it's the best price you're going to get
anywhere else they're our family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com and you can shop for the
auto and body parts that you're looking
for from hundreds of manufacturers this
catalog is unique it's uh very easy to
navigate and you can quickly see all the
parts that are available for your
vehicle and you can choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer one
thing that i hear from people that go to
rockauto.com and i and i do talk about
rockauto.com in my spare time all the
time
and one thing that everyone says is it's
very easy to find everything you look
for it's a really easy site to navigate
and they've got great selection and
great prices i've heard this myself
so many times so go to rockauto.com
right now and see all the parts
available for your car truck right walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
last week
biden announced his authoritarian
vaccine mandate which is meant to force
all companies with over 100 employees to
either
mandate vaccines or test their employees
for cove at least once a week and if you
haven't heard already the daily wire is
not going to comply for this the daily
wire could face up to fourteen thousand
dollars for each violation
it could destroy everything they've
built but um i can you know that we've
built i should say but i can't think of
a better hill to die on than opposing
medical tyranny and the erasure of
freedom that's why the daily wire is
calling on all who are listening to help
them fight this obscene and tyrannical
mandate if you join us daily wire member
right now you'll be aiding and supplying
the resources needed to take this all
the way to the supreme court if
necessary so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off americans have been
far too willing to cede their freedoms
to authoritarian bureaucrats in the name
of public health enough is enough so
please stand with us and the daily wire
and most importantly the rights of all
american citizens now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
as you have noted from the opening
public schools in virginia especially
are an unmitigated disaster maybe it's
the proximity to dc that's the problem
dc is the intellectual and spiritual
equivalent of a malfunctioning nuclear
reactor everybody in the vicinity is
soaking up the metaphorical radiation
and getting sick and that brings us to
blacksburg high school in montgomery
county in virginia where a teacher josh
thompson according to fox news
has been uh posting tick-tock videos to
share his views on white supremacy and
racism in one video he says that
whiteness is not a race but a racial
ideology listen
this is an idea that i think a lot of
people have um and i want to call that
in uh lovingly just for a moment
yes america contains many cultures and
many races that is not wrong
however
the problem comes when we don't think
about this idea or this argument
in a
racialized way when it comes to power
and power dynamics
in america as in many other parts of the
western world whiteness is the dominant
racial
ideology
so we think of power in terms of race
whiteness has the most power
so while there are people of many
different races and cultures living in
america the fact that whiteness is the
dominant racialized power structure
that is the problem and that is why we
have to involve race in all of our
arguments and considerations
this is not really the point but i have
to say i'm always annoyed and a bit
perplexed by the number of cuts and
edits these tick tockers need for a one
minute video
there's a cut after every sentence
they're not able to string together two
sentences at once i speak for an hour
straight on this show with no cuts at
all many of my sentences may be rambling
and unnecessary but at least i can put
multiple sentences together
these people have to cut and think about
the next sentence before filming and
still it ends up being incoherent
but the greater point is that this
teacher is a self-hating white freak
subjecting students to his intellectual
masochism and it gets worse listen to
josh thompson's take on pbis pbis which
stands for positive behavioral
interventions and supports and is the
framework used in virginia schools for
dealing with behavior problems now it
already sounds like permissive new age
nonsense
but uh it's still not enough for josh
apparently who believes that any attempt
to control a student's behavior is you
guessed it white supremacy i made a
comment on one of miss april's recent
videos about pbis in which i stated that
pbis is white supremacy with the hug
and a lot of y'all wanted to know more
about that so here we go
first of all thank you to jack koppa who
reminded me that
dina simmons was the first to coin this
term so thank you jack so much
so if pbis concerns itself with positive
behaviors
we have to ask ourselves okay well what
are those positive behaviors and it's
things like making sure that you're
following directions and making sure
that you're sitting quietly and you are
in your seat and all these things that
come from
white culture
the idea of just sitting quiet and being
told stuff and taking things in in a
passive stance is not a thing that's in
with many cultures so if we're
positively enforcing these behaviors we
are by extension positively enforcing
elements of white culture which
therefore keeps whiteness at the center
which is the definition of white
supremacy
what a smarmy little squirrel this guy
is
they really all are
and hey i thought what do you mean white
culture i thought white people didn't
have a culture
which is
it when they need to make uh a point
like this suddenly we as white people
have a culture but
in any other context we don't that's why
they say
you're not allowed to express pride in
being white
you know any expression of white pride
is racism
um and you can't you you can't say that
well no i i just am i'm proud of my
culture if you say that they'll say
there's no such thing as white culture
but now you're saying there is white
culture and part of white culture is
children
you know following directions and
behaving well
that sounds like a good culture can i be
proud of that
doesn't make any sense but the idea here
is that students the idea is that if
students have to sit quietly and behave
themselves and follow directions that's
something that comes from white culture
this teacher has apparently aside from
all the other contradictions decided
that the entire continent of asia does
not exist
classrooms in many parts of asia are far
more far more focused on discipline than
any classroom in the united states
that's why the average student in china
can perform calculus and build a working
space shuttle by like second grade
but josh thompson says that only white
people expect kids to behave which is
once again
the bigotry of low expectations or no
expectations rearing its head
because the obvious implication here is
that non-white students can't be
expected to behave properly or are not
capable of it
this is not only incredibly demeaning
but it's also plainly false you'll
notice how
the crt cult
makes sweeping assertions about the
nature of whiteness and and the things
that derive from whiteness but they
never make any attempt to prove any of
these assertions
this is what makes it fun and easy to be
a member of the cult it's perhaps the
primary attraction it almost makes me
want to join the cult sometimes
sometimes i want to to be a member of
the crt cult for this reason because it
just ha it must be so great
to be able to make any wild claim you
want and never be asked to justify it or
provide any evidence whatsoever
you can stand up and shout and say
spatulas are racist if you use a spatula
you're partaking white supremacy
and everybody just nods their head and
says wow i never realized that this
common kitchen instrument was racist i
didn't know that i was involving myself
in a nazi conspiracy every time i flip a
pancake my god i'm so ashamed
nobody stops and says what where are you
getting that who told you this
this is the sort of privilege afforded
to the left-wing race hustlers
with all that said
he is actually getting somewhere
within the vicinity of an important
truth
he's wrong about it being a white
supremacist ploy to tell kids to behave
themselves he's wrong about all the
racial aspects of this but he is correct
that the public school system uses a
passive quiet calm
memorization and regurgitation method of
education
it fails in that method most of the time
i mean you walk into the average public
school classroom and it's anything but
but but calm and quiet and organized
but that is the the method that the
entire system is built around
the reason why public school classrooms
are dysfunctional is because in order to
function they need all the kids to be
behaving this way but none of them
really are
and you know in fairness if you're going
to try to educate thousands of kids at a
time on a kind of industrialized
assembly line taking them from one class
to the next in 45 minute increments for
seven hours a day then you really have
no choice but to go about it this way
doesn't it doesn't work they have to
drug the kids half the kids just to make
it work and it still doesn't work but
public schools as they are currently
constructed really have no other choice
none of this has anything to do with
whiteness
and it isn't designed for white kids it
is rather as i have observed many times
including recently
it is rather designed for girls
girls thrive in that kind of educational
environment because they're better at
memorization they're better at sitting
still they're better at learning in that
way which is why k which is why girls do
better in public schools why more girls
are going to college it's why fewer
girls are drugged
education is not too white
it's too feminine
but josh thompson ideology may allow him
sometimes to get a whiff of the real
problem to come close to identifying it
yet it won't allow him to correctly
diagnose it
or prescribe the right remedies for it
and that is why he is today i must say
officially cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2021.
today on the ben shapiro show bob
woodward reports that general mark
milley contemplated handing over
american security to the chinese to
thwart president trump and the
california recall effort against gavin
newsom is a dud that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen